So many dating app users have wondered,
is my bio interesting enough?
Does my profile photo stand out?
Why can't I find a date on this thing?
Is it me or is it the way I am using the app?
It is so overwhelming sometimes
and today we're cuttin' through the confusion
and telling you exactly what you need to do
because we enlisted the help of relationship
and dating coach, Damona Hoffman.
And we teamed her up with Brooke,
a flight attendant from Nashville, Tennessee
who says she is tired of swiping without having any luck.
Well Damona, friend of the show, she is here.
Let's take a look.
Hey, Damona I'm so happy that you are able
to meet with me today.
Wonderful to meet you.
I'm Brooke Smith, I'm 30-years-old.
I am a flight attendant for the last,
I just started my seventh year.
I wanna know how I can get the most out
of maximizing my dating app experience
to get those better matches.
When I read your profile,
it reads a little bit to me more like
an Instagram feed then a profile.
I like to have my clients use the three CS.
The three CS are color, context, and character.
Color is really important in that first photo.
Particularly the color red is very attractive to men.
So you have red lipstick, which is beautiful.
You have a red Rose and you look very fun and inviting
and you're smiling there.
I want to get rid of the photos
that show more of the destination that you're at
and really focus more on the context
and then the character showing your personality,
which I think your chicken nuggets photo certainly does.
(laughing)
I think that you achieve what you're going for
when you say, "She's super fun and a little nerdy.
"Queso solves all her problems."
We just have to fill in those other photos
to show more of the context and make you the star
of your profile.
You've got all the best advice.
You have so much going for you, girl.
Damona, I am going to take your advice
and I'm gonna get right to work
on my dating app right now.
And I will see you next week with hopefully a date.
Maybe two.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Wearing the color red is alluring, ooh.
Okay, let's welcome Brooke Smith and Damona Hoffman.
(audience applauding)
Hi Damona.
Hi Drew, good to see you again.
So Damona, how are some of the common mistakes spotted
on Brooke's profile something that you think you can solve?
Well, we can solve any dating problem
and any dating app issue.
Since the last time I saw you Drew,
I actually became the official dating coach of OkCupid.
And so I see these profile problems a lot
but they are completely fixable.
What I can tell you is that, OkCupid users
who complete their profiles see 200%
more matches and you know what more matches mean?
They mean more dates.
So with a couple of little fix,
we could make a big difference for Brooke.
Brooke, how do you feel?
When I was talking to Damona, I was like,
"Gosh, she's really understanding like
what the issue is with me and dating apps.
And so I'm really excited to get right into it.
Start swiping.
Find my Mr. Right on your show.
All right, let's do it.
Okay Brooke, you are gonna go live
with your new profile right now on your dating app
and all show long, we're gonna be checking in with you
to see if you've had any success.
I mean, do you think we can hit that
in the one hour, Damona?
Oh yeah, especially with this great profile
that Brooke now has.
I'm feeling really confident about her opportunities.
Brooke, how's it going?
Any, any matches, anything?
I do have one match, Drew.
I'm pretty excited, his name's Cole.
He's 6'3, lives in New York City.
So I'm pretty, pretty pumped.
Don't know what to do now.
So, need your help.
(laughing)
Actually, I think you wanna be asking Damona
because I actually feel like I have the same question.
You get hit, Damona and I think a lot
of us women wanna go,
"Oh it's the man who's supposed to make the first move."
What do we do in this moment?
Oh no, no, no, Drew.
You cannot treat dating apps
the same way you treated offline, IRL dating, right?
It's a completely different medium.
So I've said for the longest time
that women should take control of their dating destiny.
You should be the one doing the choosing,
not waiting to get chose.
And now the data really backs this up.
That women who take initiative really do have far
more matches and more matches mean more messages
and more messages mean what?
More dates.
Okay, all right.
So think I'm gonna go for it.
All right, thank you, Damona.
That's my girl, yes.
Brooke?
Drew?
Hi, Brooke.
Hi, Damona.
Hey, Drew.
I want good news, I want good news.
What's the status?
Okay, all right, Drew.
So I meshed with Cole and his bio had said something like,
"I was crushing my goals all quarantine
"and now I'm ready to crush some hearts."
So I messaged him and I just said,
"Please don't crush my heart
"but you can surely try to win it over."
Oh.
And then from there,
I know, right?
I was proud of myself on that one,
but right in from there he immediately asked me
about my favorite TV show "Big Brother."
I told him I eat, sleep, breathe, Julie Chen, all summer.
And I'm looking for a plus one to expect the unexpected
all summer with me.
And he was totally in.
And now we've just had some witty banter back and forth
and things are going really good.
Okay, I love this.
I love how you took Demona's advice.
I love your quippy comeback, it's adorable.
I'm glad he bit, it doesn't surprise me.
Now Damona, how should Brooke proceed from here?
She's got him on the hook.
Things are going well, but where do we go from here?
And frankly, how do we not screw it up?
What now?
Well, first of all, you can't screw it up.
If it's the right person it's going to work out.
So just move forward with that confidence, Brooke.
But we're off to a strong start.
What I don't want you to do though,
is get stuck in the texting trap.
You know, that cycle when you're just sending messages
back and forth and back and forth, and you're like,
hey is anybody going to make a move here?
You want to move things to the next phase
which can be a phone call.
I love the phone call.
And then you can really get a sense of who he is
and whether you want to move offline.
And then you gotta get on to that date.
You can't really tell who somebody is
or effectively filter through your dates
on messaging or on text.
You have to actually meet face-to-face
and see if you really like each other.
I'm super excited, super excited.
He seems to literally feed off my energy
which is pretty hard to do sometimes with me,
so I love it, I'm so excited.
Great, I love this and Damona,
you are so smart when it comes to this stuff.
Thank gosh you're leading the charge.
You're so wise, so thank you, Damona Hoffman.
Thank you, Brooke Smith.
We can't wait to find out what happens next.
Thank you, Drew Barrymore.
I love this, to all of you who are watching at home,
I hope you appreciated Damona's wisdom.
I know I get so much out of it
and thank you for spending your time with us today.
We know you could spend it anywhere.
Thanks for choosing to hang out here.
We hope to see you soon.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)